[Music]
you've said that you prefer wearing as
little clothing as possible again this
is just a different item you'd like to
be naked you like to be naked you prefer
being native and clothes people yeah I
mean that's just that's natural
I just find clothes restricting and I
just I mean when I get home I just want
to be naked no creep on the my family
has always been a very comfortable
comfortably naked family the guys
stories I don't really want to tell on
national television
what's here I mean my family is just
sort of an open we're very open there
was no you know what I mean they were
your Norman Rockwell Thanksgiving
painting is all of you were naked Turkey
yeah I mean my mom I mean my mom was a
day look when you're also in your dancer
you're very comfortable with your body
you know what I mean you just sort of my
mom was a dancer that was her so you
know mom would come flying down the
stairs and we'd have all of our friends
there and she being like little tiny
numbers and I'd like mom like do not
cover yourself right did you get older
like okay let's just all this just
because let's be you know take it off
where do you live I know you know it's a
very comfortable it's it's funny because
I think in a way it's more advanced
because I've talked about this a lot I
come from people that have a lot of body
shame right and we have we have good
reason but we were like covered up all
the time and my wife is always saying
like wait for laughs yeah she'll see me
in the shower and I'll be wearing like a
1920s bathing suit
that's like okay here and down to here
and I've got the goggles on what are you
doing I've already memorized your entire
body no she's never she never will I
think it's good you know I think part of
actually what my book sort of opens with
his acceptance and that moment where you
go okay well I'm gonna actually just
take a good look at what's right in
front of me in the mirror and get
comfortable with it because it's mine
and accept it and and I that's the
family you know that I come from yeah I
think it's also when you when you have
kids I have kids when they're little
they don't they're naked and they're
running around and it was me that was
always like cover up you you know I was
laying on the shame of course when they
get into their 30s it's more of you know
you're driving down the road you want
them dressed but but for the most part
it's it's we're the ones that are
putting that on yeah well I mean you
know it is it's our natural state I
guess it's just nice
you